well the moment you've been waiting for
our face off with derek engelin he sat
down with chris matthews they talked
about the first
golden knights outdoor game and it is
time to face off with derek england the
knights are wrapping up a four game
series with the avalanche even as we
speak so join us tonight at 11 for
highlights of that
like to welcome once again derek england
back to channel 8 as we face off here
derek let's talk about that weekend and
tall because that outdoor game how many
seconds
into that first period did you realize
oh this ice isn't going to hold up
yeah right away when they started fixing
the ice after the
national anthem you knew it was a little
soft and
um talking to shane 90 the night before
they were out on the ice with some
police officers and he said it was
fairly soft then so the soft ice
the nhl is looking at um you know safety
first and foremost you don't want to
you want this event to be big every year
and you don't want guys getting injuries
and with soft ice
you know you're pushing you're doing a
full stride you want it to hold you
don't want to slip out that's when you
start tearing groins and
and stuff like that and i think on top
of that
they want a good product if the ice is
really bad the puck's bouncing
you know they're not gonna those star
players aren't gonna make those
big plays and stuff like that they're
still gonna make big good plays and
stuff but
they wanted optimal ice conditioning for
for the game
you know when we talked about this too
the knights fell behind in that game the
game before that
it's like in basketball or football
where you fall behind early now you're
always chasing and it's just difficult
to catch up
and capture a lead yeah definitely
especially with the
great teams you know colorado's a great
team and they get come out on the lead
same as when the knights get the lead
they they're gonna not sit back
but they're gonna they're gonna play a
little smarter they're not gonna pinch
as hard and um you know when you're
chasing him your
your d are pinching down the walls every
time and if if the defending team is
good on the walls and stuff that's when
you get the odd man rushes and
you know you're pushing forward and
you're you might give up a few few
chances and
you don't want to be chasing you want to
get that first goal and play with the
lead and
play a smart game real quick question
derek before we let you go you were up
there in tahoe for the weekend
uh just your experience up there
watching the game hanging out with bill
foley and having a good time
yeah it was great it was um a beautiful
beautiful uh a spot up there even
without the hockey game it's beautiful
and
to go up there and have a hockey game on
the lake it's uh um
pretty pretty amazing as part of two
outdoor games which uh
this is a whole different thing you know
it brings you back to those
childhood days of playing out on the
lake or on the pond and
you know i think the guys really enjoyed
it well they wouldn't have to twist our
arms to go back would they no
definitely not all right thank you very
much derek we appreciate you coming here
once again as we face off each and every
monday
at 6 45 right here on channel 8. now
after tonight of course
uh the vegas gold knights will play san
jose and anaheim before coming back to
face the wild
on march first so it's it's boy it's
boom boom boom every game
yeah every other day it's a game so uh
they gotta rest and uh
have a good game tonight and then get
ready for the next one